será la llegada de rafael world que será
el primer senador afroamericano por
georgia el décimo primer senador
afroamericano en la historia de eeuu y
de jong o soft el primer senador judío
por georgia y el más joven en toda la
cámara alta esto implica la mayoría en
la cámara alta en el senado porque en
este momento las sillas están
de esta forma 50 para los republicanos
50 para los demócratas pero como la
vicepresidenta kamala harris actúa como
presidenta del senado también pues la
balanza se inclina hacia los demócratas
eso quiere decir que la ley de
presupuesto por ejemplo de 1,9 mil
millones de dólares que quiera probar de
joe biden de cara a la pandemia se va a
aprobar
muy probablemente mucho más fácil que si
tuvieran los republicanos la mayoría en
la cámara alta en reemplazo de kamala
harris estará alex padilla
que era el secretario de estado para
california y estará reemplazando la
silla de kamala harris en el senado
ahora cristóbal que sabemos de la
batería de órdenes ejecutivas que vayan
firmo para revertir las políticas de
donald trump
claro ya desde el salón oval el
presidente yo valiente le dijo a los
periodistas que no hay tiempo que perder
y que ya empezó a firmar estas 17
órdenes ejecutivas que pretenden
revertir lo que había hecho el
presidente saliente ex presidente donald
trump en temas energéticos por ejemplo
cancelando el proyecto de energía xl
que es un oleoducto que va desde el
norte hasta el sur en texas cancelando
por ejemplo las limitaciones de entrada
a ciudadanos de países de mayoría
musulmana parando la construcción del
muro volviendo a el acuerdo climático de
parís y regresando también a la
organización mundial de la salud no hay
tiempo que perder y trump
perdón y bailén quiere aprovechar al
máximo sus primeros días en la casa
blanca